[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 y precisamente continuamos
en francia- rosa pérez más de bienvenida
feliz mañana de lunes vamos a hablar
como lo dije de lo que ocurre en francia
políticamente hablando tras este
escándalo que ha revelado hasta
investigación del consorcio de
periodistas internacionales que
investigan además del diario the
guardian donde también ese público y es
que las políticas de wear pues no están
siendo vistas de buena manera no
hicieron digamos un buen trabajo con un
lobby político donde también el
presidente francés el mismo creo que
estuvo involucrado en poder ayudar a
esta compañía a expandirse rosa buenos
días raúl exactamente no uber desde hace
tiempo que esa foco de la polémica desde
que irrumpió en los mercados
internacionales básicamente sobre todo
por sus prácticas de competencia desleal
frente al sector del taxi sin embargo
esta investigación que como decías es
una investigación global coordinada por
el comité internacional de periodistas
de investigación
revela en la práctica a través de 124
mil archivos de los cuales 83 mil son a
correos como se daba a la práctica y
cómo se tramaba todas estas políticas
tan agresivas a la hora de expandirse
bien como bien decía estos documentos
estos a cientos de miles de documentos
fueron filtrados en un primer lugar al
medio británico the gardian que lo paso
hasta el comité internacional de
periodistas de investigación que ha
hecho partícipe a decenas de medios de
comunicación de todo el mundo de esta
investigación y vamos a seleccionar por
lo tanto algunos de estos medios de
distintas regiones para abordar algunos
de los puntos de esta gigantesca
investigación vamos entonces a empezar
rosa como bien lo decíamos con the
gardian exactamente y titula y resume de
una forma digamos muy clara una
filtración de documentos a la que nos
referíamos confidenciales ha revelado la
historia interna de como la compañía
tecnológica de sillicon valley violó las
leyes engaño la policía explotó la
violencia contra los conductores y
presionó agresivamente a los gobiernos
durante
expansión global bien particularmente
vamos a hacer referencia al apartado que
the gardian dedica al llamado que el
switch o botón de pánico se podría
traducir al español digamos un bloqueo a
los servidores de uber durante las
redadas y las investigaciones policiales
o judiciales no precisamente en estos
correos se muestra como el propio galán
y el que fuera hacía de uber ordenó
personalmente el uso del botón de pánico
mientras la policía estaba en su sede de
ámsterdam en unos mensajes
intercambiados dice por favor activen el
kill switch lo antes posible hay que
cerrar el acceso en ámsterdam bien no a
una de los a uno de los puntos que
comentábamos esta obstrucción a la
justicia para evitar que las autoridades
digamos indagarán en sus a en sus
finanzas en sus prácticas etcétera el
país de españa rosa que dice en este
caso nos fijamos en lo que veníamos
comentando de la competencia desleal y
de las condiciones de los trabajadores
recordemos que über incluso raúl esto
para puntualizar resumir brevemente
ha dado nombre a todo un modelo
económico la humanización de la economía
porque pone digamos en marcha está este
modelo de poner en contacto oferta y
demanda pero sin embargo ellos se llevan
una importante comisión de un 25 por
ciento no ya la práctica trata a sus
trabajadores como si fueran esos
trabajadores a pesar de que legalmente
no lo sean esto ha generado muchísimos
problemas en todo el mundo por el
estatuto precisamente de estos
trabajadores que se quejan de la
necesidad de hacer horarios
abusivos no y precisamente en relación a
estas prácticas se filtró un mensaje
también de ejecutivos de uber diciendo a
veces tenemos problemas porque bueno es
que somos jodidamente ilegales resume un
correo interno que estudió cómo
enfrentarse a los taxistas y cambiar la
legislación precisamente también en este
sentido en las peleas entre uber y taxis
señalan distintos medios de comunicación
como uber hacía uso de estas peleas de
las imágenes violentas contra
conductores de uber por un lado para
degradar la imagen de los taxistas por
otro lado para ganar apoyo a su favor la
nación de argentina rosa
la nación de argentina señala también
evasión de impuestos por parte de la
compañía por otro lado también aquí en
américa el washington post señala el
papel sobre todo de emanuel macrón
cuando era ministro de economía de
francia entre 2014 y 2016 y esta es una
de las claves de esta investigación
porque es digamos la figura de más alto
nivel que se ve salpicada por estas
prácticas y de hecho raúl para ya darles
a ustedes un inicio en esta
investigación para que puedan entrar a
la página web de la comité de
periodistas de investigación
internacionales veamos el siguiente
gráfico para que ustedes puedan ver de
qué se trata este interactivo vemos como
la figura de macrón es de las más
destacadas entre las personas claves que
figuran en esta investigación por como
precisamente ante un bloqueo político y
gubernamental del elíseo en ese momento
que no veía con buenos ojos la irrupción
de esta compañía en francia precisamente
por lo que decíamos la competencia
desleal con el taxista con los taxistas
y digamos sus políticas
laborales muy criticables macro no jugó
un papel fundamental para ayudarles a
entrar en el estado francés y como
tenían digamos línea directo con línea
directa con el actual presidente franz
pues rosa muchisimas gracias como
siempre por toda la revista de prensa
del día de hoy pues hablando de este
escándalo político como le decíamos
salpica al presidente actual francés
emmanuel macro no exactamente y
solamente cerrar e insistiendo en que
estos documentos hacen referencia a un
periodo entre 2013 y 2017 que ahora muy
atrás ministro de economía exactamente
hay que ver dice que ya no se trata de
la misma empresa después de que los
inversionistas se esforzarán la dimisión
de calañas pero bueno las políticas
laborales están ahí no raúl lo sabe
gracias pasamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado el día